These dumplings are made
of real shrimp meat,
but instead of being farmed
in water tanks or rivers,
this shrimp is grown in the lab
by Singapore-based startup Shiok Meats.
Globally, we are the only company
working on cell-based shrimp and crab.
Since we are making this
from the actual cells
to the DNA level, the
nutrition as well as the taste
is exactly the same as
the original product.
Around the world,
startups like Shiok Meats
are racing to invent
and improve alternatives
to traditional meat production,
which is often criticized
for environmental and ethical reasons.
The advantages of using
cellular agriculture
to make seafood is that
you don't need to set up large-scale farms
or going to the oceans
to catch these animals
for human consumption, so
environmentally friendly.
There is very less
greenhouse gas emissions
or carbon emissions as well,
and it's animal friendly
because we don't slaughter
animals in large scale.
Plant-based meats are already here.
Alternative proteins
from homegrown insects
are on their way.
And now with advances in technology,
cell-based seafood could soon
be coming to a table near you.
So ever since I've known,
I was always intrigued by the human body.
So I wanted to kind of know
how the human body works,
how does digestion happen,
how does blood flow,
how does the brain work and all of that,
and always imagined
myself being in biology.
This passion brought Sandyha Sriram
from her home country India to Singapore
where she got a PhD degree
in Biological Science
and co-founded two other tech companies
before starting Shiok Meats in 2018.
I've been a vegetarian all my life
for ethical, more environmental reasons.
I just put my skill for
biology and my love for food
and my love for sort of
saving this environment
and doing my part in this world together
and said, why not grow
seafood using stem cells?
Cultured meat is not new.
In 2013, Dutch professor Mark Post
created the world's first
burger patty from cells.
So far more than 60 companies
have joined this field,
backed by increasing
funding from investors.
And the cell-based meat
market is projected to reach
$140 billion in the next decade.
Cultured chicken developed
by startup Eat Just
was approved for commercial
sale in Singapore last December
a first for a cultured meat product.
But while many companies are
working on cultured chicken,
beef and duck meat,
Shiok focuses on seafood.
So shrimp crab and lobster
alone makes about $150 billion
worth of market share in the world.
And Asia is the largest
producer, consumer and exporter
of these proteins.
And it's well-liked by all of us,
and we consume a lot of crustaceans.
So the process of growing
cell-based meat or seafood
involves three main steps.
The first step is where
you isolate the stem cells
from live animals.
These are the source cells of any animal,
sort of the birth cell that
can grow into any organ.
And these cells are then
put into large-scale tanks
called bioreactors, which are
pretty much like a brewery.
But instead of brewing beer,
it's brewing meats and seafood.
And we feed these cells
with liquid nutrients
that convert these cells into
the actual tissue, muscle fat,
connective tissue and real
meat at the end of the day
that has the same taste, nutrition
and eventually the same
texture and look as well.
Compared with farmed seafood,
these cultured versions are friendlier
to animals and the planet.
Shiok Meats says growing cultured seafood
is also at least six times
faster than farming them.
But it's pricey.
A kilogram of cultured shrimp
costs nearly a thousand U.S. dollars.
The key reason: the
liquid nutrient solution
that helps the seafood to grow
is an expensive pharmaceutical product
used to make things like vaccines.
When we started off,
the liquid nutrient mix
that we used to feed our cells
used to be pharmaceutical grade,
because that was the only
thing available out there.
But what we've managed to
do in two and a half years
is to swap out some of the
chemicals with plant extracts
or edible products that makes
the food more nutritious
and delicious as well.
And eventually our
process will involve 100%
plant-based and edible nutrients.
And we are aiming to be
at about $50 per kilogram
by the end of this year.
The company also faces another hurdle-
how to make this novel lab-grown food
appealing to customers.
We're looking forward to sort of breaking
the myths that are out there
and making people understand
that this is the future
and it's as safe for them as possible.
And it's the same meat and seafood
that they're used to eating.
Shiok Meats has raised
over 20 million dollars in funding
and plans to launch their products
within the next two years.
Yet it might still take
years, even decades,
for cultured meat and
seafood to go mainstream,
but Sandhya remains hopeful.
Our mission is to feed the 10 billion
that we will be in the
next couple of decades
and the ever-growing
population after that.
As a consumer, you walk into a supermarket
and you go to the frozen
aisle of meat and seafood,
and you see everything from
cell-based meat and seafood
to plant-based meat and seafood
and a small section of
conventional meat and seafood.
And that's sort of the vision
for the entire industry
and for Shiok Meats as well.